SUBCOMMITTEE FOR TODAY WE'LL
DISCUSS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS FOR VARIOUS STATE
DEPARTMENTS -- WILL HAVE A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW ALSO STARS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHERS THE
BULLY CALENDAR BUT SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM.
WE'RE GOING TO START TARA I'M TO
BE HEARD.
THE FIRST WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COUNTY VOTING SYSTEMS
INFORMATIONAL ONLY
.
ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SUSAN LAPSLEY DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF STATE IT'S A TRAY STATES
OFFICE -- IN GENERAL I'M
CHANNELING AND SHE FOR THE
ELECTIONS DIVISION PRESS
SECRETARY STATE.
I WOULD HAVE PREPARED REMARKS
BUT IF YOU HAVE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THOSE AT THE OUTSET OTHERWISE --
WE TALK ABOUT THE AB.
DECERTIFICATION OF VOTING
SYSTEMS VOTERS CHOICE ACT -- AND
ANYTHING ELSE YOU MAY WANT TO TO
SURE PLEASE PROCEED.
SO WE WANT TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THE NUMEROUS
ACTIVITIES THAT WERE DOING THAT
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER WAY TO
PREPARE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTIONS.
WERE IN THE PROCESS OF TRAINING
CALIFORNIA ELECTION OFFICIALS ON
CYBERSECURITY PREPAREDNESS WITH
MAINTENANCE PRACTICES CANNOT
FIND WHICH NOT REPORTING AND ALL
OF OUR IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE'RE
DOING ON A STATEWIDE VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM VOEPEL.
WERE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING IN AS THE NEW LAWS
WERE PASSED LAST YEAR REGARDING
POSTAGE PAID FOR BY MAIL AN
ENVELOPE DESIGN FOR PROVISIONAL
BALLOT ENVELOPES.
AFFIDAVITS REGISTRATION -- OUR
REMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE BY MAIL
TO BE EXPANDED STATEWIDE.
ARE VOTE BY MAIL TRACKING
SYSTEMS THAT WERE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING AND
THE ONLINE OFFICE HOLDER LOOK UP
TOOL.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
COUNTIES WHO ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT MODEL
FOR TWO AND TWENTY TWENTY AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT IMPROVEMENTS
FOR CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION AND WAIT TIMES.
DURING THE PROCESS OF A DINNER
PUBLICATIONS IN OUR FORESTS
RELATED TO ALL THE NEW
LEGISLATION.
AND REDESIGNING OR VOTER
NOTIFICATION CARD WERE IMPROVING
THE PROCESS FOR THE GENERALLY
RECOGNIZED CANDIDATES FOR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES AS WELL
AS PREPARING FOR THE PRIMARY.
AND PRIMARY ELECTION CALENDAR
AND THE ELECTION GUIDE FOR THE
PROCESS OF DRAFTING REGULATIONS
RELATED TO RESPOND ANY DOT IT'S
IN OUR VOTE CAL STATE WEBER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM AS WELL AS
UPDATING OUT REACH MATERIALS
WHICH INCLUDES NOTICES FOR
CROSSOVER VOTERS FOR
PRESIDENTIAL.
PRIMARY -- ARE ALSO EXPANDING
THE VOTE SURE CAMPAIGN FOR CYBER
SECURITY AWARENESS TO COMBAT
MISINFORMATION REGARDING VOTING.
AND SUSAN WILL GO INTO A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE TESTING AND
CERTIFICATION OF VOTING SYSTEMS
THAT ABUSING.
TWENTY TWENTY THANKS TENANTS.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS -- THE
SECTOR STATE HAS SPONSORED AND
AND HAVE LEGISLATION THAT HAS
BEEN PASSED THE SPOT.
LOTS OF CHANGES TO CALIFORNIA --
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION --
ALSO ANYWAY AS JANET DISCUSSED
OF ADMINISTERING THE ELECTIONS
KNOWN AS THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT
AND ALSO WORKING WITH MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO BRING FUNDING
FOR STATE AND VOTING SYSTEM
UPGRADES AND REPLACEMENT -- IS A
STATE SENATORS ATTRIBUTE THE
AUTHORS SB THREE SIXTY WHICH
TOOK EFFECT GENERAL ONE TWENTY
FOURTEEN A PUT CALIFORNIA ON
FRONT IN PURSUING EXPANDED
OPTIONS FOR MORE MODERNIZING
VOTING SYSTEMS.
WHILE PRESERVING IN CODIFYING
SOME OF THE HIGHEST STANDARDS
FOR SECURE SECURITY TESTING AND
CERTIFICATION OF VOTING SYSTEMS
IN THE COUNTRY.
AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE AGING
VOTING SYSTEMS ARE ONE OF THE
GREATEST THREATS THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR ELECTIONS THIS IS BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY THE BRENNAN CENTER.
THE BY PERSON PRESIDENTIAL
COMMISSION AND ART CALIFORNIA SO
ON LA -- VOTING SYSTEMS IN THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
ARE AT OR NEAR THEIR LIFE
EXPECTANCY MANY COUNTIES HAVE
VOTING MACHINES THAT ARE IN NEED
OF REPLACEMENT PARTS THAT ARE NO
LONGER MANUFACTURED SOME
COUNTIES HAVE EQUIPMENT THAT YOU
LIKE.
UTILIZED OPERATING SYSTEM SO ALL
THE VENDORS NO LONGER SUPPORT
THEM AND THEY CAN NO LONGER FIND
PARTS.
AGAIN WITH THE HELP OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND AND OTHERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE WERE ABLE TO
SECURE A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO UPGRADE OR
PLACE AGING VOTING SYSTEMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS BUDGET ALLOCATION WAS
ESSENTIAL.
IN ORDER TO ACCELERATE THE
PROCESS FOR ENSURING THAT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S VOTING SYSTEMS MEET
THE MOST MODERN AND EXTENSIVE
TESTING STANDARDS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE WE REFER TO
AS A CALIFORNIA VOTING SYSTEM
STANDARDS OR CVS S..
WE INITIATED THE PROCESS FOR
WITHDRAWING THE CERTIFICATION OR
CONDITIONAL APPROVAL FOR VOTING
SYSTEMS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
GRANTED IF THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
TESTED AND CERTIFIED TO CVS S..
MANY CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ARE
ALREADY WELL ON THEIR WAY
TOWARDS ADOPTING NEW CVS THAT'S
COMPLIANCE SYSTEMS IN FACT
TWENTY COUNTIES HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED SUCH SYSTEMS AND
MANY ARE IN THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESS. FOR REFERENCE ARE
CURRENTLY THREE VOTING SYSTEMS
OF INTESTINE CERTIFIED TO
CALIFORNIA BUT VOTING SYSTEM
STANDARDS DOMINIONS VOTING.
AT INKS DEMOCRACY THREE FIVE
POINT TWO VOTING SYSTEM THE
COUNTY LOS ANGELES VOTING
SYSTEMS FOR ALL PEOPLE TELL THE
SYSTEM ONE POINT.
OH HEART INNER CIVICS VERY
VOTING THREE POINT ZERO POINT.
ONE AND IN ADDITION THERE ARE
THREE MORE VOTING SYSTEMS
CURRENTLY BEING TESTED RIGHT NOW
WITHIN SECTORS STATES OFFICE FOR
AT MEETING AND AND SO BEING
CERTIFIED TO THE CVS S. AND
THEIR DOMINIONS.
DEMOCRACY SUITE FIVE POINT ONE
ZERO L. A.'S AT THE SEPT TALLY
TWO POINT.
OH AND YES NESS AT WHICH IS
ELECTION SYSTEMS SOFTWARE'S EBS
SIX POINT ZERO POINT FOUR POINT.
TWO THE WITHDRAWAL OF SERB
OCCASIONAL CONDITIONAL APPROVAL
IS EFFECTIVE AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH 2019% ELECTIONS CODE
SECTION NINETEEN TWO THREE TWO
ANY ELECTION CONDUCTED SIX
MONTHS FROM OCT.
AUGUST TWENTY SEVEN SHALL NOT BE
AFFECTED BY THIS ACTION.
THEREFORE ANY FEDERAL STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL DISTRICT OR
SCHOOL ELECTION FROM CONDUCTED
FROM AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH
THROUGH FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY MAY CONTINUE TO
USE THE VOTING SYSTEMS
PREVIOUSLY CERTIFIED.
OR APPROVED EVEN IT IF IT HAS
NOT BEEN TESTED AND CERTIFIED TO
CBS S..
NOW HAVING SAID THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WORK IN CHALLENGE
TO IMPLEMENTING A NEW SYSTEM
VOTING SYSTEM FOR COUNTY MAY AND
AND INVOLVE -- THERE MAY BE A
UNIQUE SENSE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
COULD IMPEDE JURISDICTION FROM
PROCURING IMPLEMENTING A CVS A
CERTIFIED SYSTEM BY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH THE TWENTY TWENTY
INCLUDING SUCH THINGS AS DELAYS
IN THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS OR
COUNTY FUNDING OR BOARD APPROVAL.
OR EVEN THE PRACTICAL JUST SIX
OF TRAINING AND EDUCATING POLL
WORKERS STAFFS AND VOTERS.
THEREFORE FOR ANY ELECTION
CONDUCTED AFTER FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY IN WHICH A
COUNTY BELIEVES THEY NEED TO USE
A DECERTIFIED SYSTEM A WRITTEN
REQUEST FOR CONDITIONAL APPROVAL
FOR EXTENSION USE WILL BE
CONSIDERED BY OUR OFFICE BY IF
IT'S A MINIATURE US BY APRIL
FIFTH TWENTY NINETEEN SO JUST.
THIS FRIDAY.
THOSE ARE BECAUSE MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO US IN WRITING
INCLUDES THE JURISDICTIONS
JUSTIFICATION FOR EXTENSION OF
USE OF THE PLAN AND SCHEDULE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE CVS CERTIFIED
SYSTEM WHICH IT SHOULD INCLUDE.
THE DETAILED PLAN FOR
PROCUREMENT AND STAFF TRAINING
AS WELL AS A SPECIFIC FINAL
IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
AS OF TODAY WE HAVE THREE AT A
COUNTIES THAT HAVE REQUESTED
EXTENSION TO US I ANTICIPATE
THAT -- COME FRIDAY WE WILL HAVE
MANY MORE THAT ARE SUBMITTED TO
US BUT AT THIS POINT IN TIME WE
DON'T KNOW WHO THOSE ARE IT --
BUT CAN PROVIDE AN UPDATE AT
THAT TIME SURE THE SERGEANTS CAN
CALL THE UP THE MEMBERS AND
REPORT.
IT QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU BEFORE
YOU MOVE ON DO YOU KNOW WHICH
COUNTIES MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
UPGRADE THEIR VOTING SYSTEMS.
IN TIME FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION.
SO I THINK THAT APRIL FIF
DEADLINE WILL HAVE A BETTER IDEA
OF A BIRD RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AT
TO COUNTIES THAT HAVE SUBMITTED
OR THREE COUNTIES AND I'M GONNA
FOR AND BLINKING ON THE THIRD --
ONE THAT HAVE ARE GOING TO DO A
PHASED APPROACH SO THE THEY MAY
NOT MAKE THAT -- FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH DATE FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION BUT THEY'LL HAVE
IT.
PART WAY IMPLEMENTED THERE WERE
TWENTY SEVEN FULL IMPLEMENTATION
BY NOVEMBER.
THANK YOU L. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE. FOR EVERYBODY ON HOW
MUCH MORE MONEY WOULD BE NEEDED
TO BRING ALL COUNTY VOTING
SYSTEMS UP TO DATE.
SO I THINK THAT THE AS AS
ELECTION OFFICIALS WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE FULL AMOUNT
THAT WE HAD LOOKED AT WOULD COST
FOR ALL COUNTIES IF ITS STATE
PAID FOR EVERYTHING IS FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
THE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
THAT WE RECEIVED IN THIS YEAR
STATE BUDGET THE BUDGET WAS A
WITH A ONE TO ONE MATCH SO FIFTY
FIFTY MATCH FOR COUNTY SO.
WE STILL MAINTAIN THAT FOR
COUNTIES TO REPLACE THEIR FULL
SYSTEMS AGAIN IF WE'RE PAYING
FOR THE FULL BILL IT WOULD BE
THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
THERE'S WITH WHAT ROOM WHEN
THEY'RE DEPENDING ON THE MATCHES
AND AND ADD THE MODELS THAT WE
GO WITH.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPERATIVE
THAT WE CONSIDER ON GOING AND
FUNDING OF ELECTIONS ON ONGOING
BASIS NOT ONCE EVERY FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY YEARS WHEN ALL THE WILL
START FALLING OFF THE BUS.
SURE AND MORE QUESTION FOR
EVERYBODY ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ITEMS THAT NEED TO BE FUNDED
PRIOR TO TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
TO HELP INSURE SUCCESSFUL.
BOOK ASH BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF THINGS.
I THINK THERE'S SEVERAL THINGS
THAT THAT WE HAVE IN OUR IN OUR
AND BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT.
AS WITH APPROVAL OF THOSE WILL
GO A LONG WAY.
MR TOO MANY QUESTIONS.
A PROVIDING FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
VOTING SYSTEMS FLICKING CARRY
OUT ELECTIONS IS THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE.
THE STATE APPROVED A HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR MILLION LAST YEAR
HOWEVER THAT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH
OF IT IS REFERRED. TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIA SYSTEMS MEET THE
STANDARDS -- THIS WAS
INFORMATION ONLY SO.
THAT HAVE TO THIS ITEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER --
TWO CALIFORNIA PART OF THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR
ME ALRIGHT.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BETH MISSION SKIN I'M CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS FOR THE VETERANS
HOMES VISION AND I HAVE HERE
WITH ME TODAY THOMAS MARTIN.
OUR DIRECTOR OF FUTURE
OPERATIONS AND PLANNING.
FIRST THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE -- THIS
UPDATE ON RECENT RESEARCH AND
PLANNING THAT WE HAVE UNDER WAY
AS PART OF THE MASTER PLAN
DIRECTION THAT WAS GIVEN TO US A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO -- I WILL IF
PROVIDED THIS WORKS FOR YOU I'LL
PROVIDE A BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE
HISTORY OF HOW WE GOT TO WHERE
WE ARE IN THIS PROJECT.
AND THEN THOMAS AND I ARE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT ANY
VIEW OF TWO YEARS AGO AS PART OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED CALVET TO
CONDUCT A MASTER PLANNING EFFORT
FOR THE VETERANS HOMES.
I BELIEVE THIS CAME FROM A
COMMON OUR COLLECTIVE
RECOGNITION THAT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERAN POPULATION IS EVOLVING.
IN ITS THE CLINICAL NEEDS AND
IT'S AN AS ITS INTEREST AS NEW
GENERATIONS OF SERVICE MEMBERS
LEAVE THE MILITARY.
RETURN TO CIVILIAN LIFE AND
EVENTUALLY ARE IN NEED OF LONG
TERM CARE SERVICES.
INDEED WE ALREADY ARE SEEING
SOME DIFFERENCES AMONG OUR OUR
CURRENT VETERANS HOME RESIDENTS
AND WE AGREE THAT OVER TIME
VETERANS NEEDS AND INTERESTS.
AND EXPECTATIONS WILL CONTINUE
TO CHANGE.
THIS CONCEPT PLUS MAKING SURE
THAT THE STATE'S FUNDING AND
RESOURCES CONTINUE TO BE SPENT
MOST EFFECTIVELY AMID ALL THESE
EVOLUTIONS ARE AT THE HEART OF
THE DESIGN OF THIS PROJECT.
WHAT WE ALL WILL GAIN FROM THIS
FROM THIS OUR ANSWERS TO CERTAIN
QUESTIONS WHO SHOULD WE BE IN
TEN TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS?
WHAT DO WE DO BEST WHERE WE MOST
NEEDED WHAT SHOULD WE PROVIDE TO
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS WHO ARE IN
NEED OF LONG TERM CARE AND OTHER
HEALTH SERVICES?
IN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL Vì ã AND AS A
COMPLEMENT TO THEIR PROGRAMMING.
DURING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
PROCESS A YEAR AFTER THE INITIAL
DIRECTION THAT WAS GIVEN TO US
THE LEGISLATURE ADDED SOME
LANGUAGE AS WELL AS A COUPLE AS
WELL AS A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS.
INCLUDING THAT OUR MASTER
PLANNING EFFORTS BE ON GOING AND
THAT OUR PRODUCT BE UPDATED
REGULARLY.
IN CONNECTION WITH THIS THE
LATTER LANGUAGE PROVIDED AN
EXTENSION TO OUR INITIAL JUNE
THIRTIETH -- EADLINE AND OUR
FINAL PRODUCT WILL BE PROVIDED
TO YOU BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF THIS YEAR.
AFTER GETTING THE INITIAL
DIRECTION WE EMBARKED ON
DESIGNING THE PROJECT AND HIRED
TO STAFF TO SERVE AS A RESEARCH
TEAM.
WE STRUCTURE THE EFFORT SO THAT
IT HAS TWO PIECES TO IT THAT WE
EXPLORED SIMULTANEOUSLY AND ARE
MERGING IN A FINAL PRODUCT.
THE TWO PIECES BEING A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA VETERAN
POPULATION WILL LOOK LIKE.
WHAT THEY WILL NEED AND WHERE
THESE SERVICES SHOULD BE LOCATED?
AND THEN THE OTHER PIECE BEING A
THOROUGH REVIEW OF OUR VETERANS
HOME PROPERTIES WHAT ARE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE WHAT ARE THE
LIMITATIONS.
OF WHAT ARE THE CREATIVE IDEAS
AND WHAT CAN WE LEARN FROM
INDUSTRY -- AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M PROUD TO SAY OUR RESEARCH
HAS BEEN GOING VERY SUCCESSFULLY
PROVIDING US SOME VERY VALUABLE
INSIGHT AND LENDING ITSELF. TO
TO WHAT I KNOW WILL BE A USEFUL
TOOL FOR ALL OF THIS FOR ALL OF
US.
WITH THAT WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
THANK YOU.
L. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE.
MR TO QUESTIONS -- FOR CALVET
CAN YOU SHARE ANY PRELIMINARY
FINDINGS FROM THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE SO FAR TO VOTE THE MASTER
PLAN.
ANYTHING SURPRISING -- EXPECTED.
I SURE SO US AGAIN MINES THOMAS
MARNHAM DIRECTOR FUTURE
OPERATIONS AND PLANNING -- SO
WITH SO AGAIN WE'RE STILL WE'RE
STILL COLLECTING A LOT OF DATA
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF DATA FROM THE
VA FROM INDUSTRY VARIOUS
ENTITIES -- ONE THING WHERE ONE
THING WE'RE WE'RE CERTAINLY
SEEING IS THERE WE KNOW THERE'S
GONNA BE A DECREASE IN VETERANS
OVERALL -- COMING UP THE NEXT AT
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS -- THAT'S
KIND OF A NATURAL DECLINE YOU
CONSIDER WE HAVEN'T HAD A DRAFT
IN WHILE.
AND WE'RE GONNA SEE A REDUCTION
OVERALL IN THE NUMBER OF
VETERANS BUT THE THE PART THAT'S
GONNA BE MORE COMPLICATED THOUGH
IS THAT THE RESIDENT THE
VETERANS -- VETERANS WILL BE
HERE IN TEN TWENTY YEARS THEY'RE
ALSO MORE LIKELY TO HAVE VARIOUS.
HEALTH CARE NEEDS TO INCLUDE
LONG TERM CARE IN PARTICULAR --
SO YOU KNOW OUR OUR AGE ARE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO HONE IN ON IS
KIND OF WHERE THAT WITHOUT NEXUS
IS YOU KNOW WHERE THOSE TWO
LINES MAYBE CROSS -- TO GET A
GOOD SENSE OF WHAT THE ACTUAL
WITH THE ACTUAL DEMAND AT THAT
TIME AS BUT YOU KNOW THE OTHER
DAY WHAT'S GOING TO BE PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT IS IS --
IDENTIFYING -- THE BEST APPROACH
TO TO MEET THOSE DEMANDS A RALLY
IS YOU KNOW WE WE BEING TELL
THAT TO THE STATE -- THAT WE CAN
WIN THERE ISN'T THERE ARE
INFINITE RESOURCES PRIDE EVERY
TYPE OF SERVICE TO EVERYONE SO
IT'S REALLY MATTER OF
IDENTIFYING WHERE.
WHERE CALVET IS THE BEST
POSITION TO PROVIDE SERVICES
WHAT TYPES OF VETERANS -- EITHER
BASED ON THEIR NEEDS AND OR
THEIR SERVICE RECORDS -- WHERE
WE ARE BEST POSITIONED TO SERVE
THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST --
IT'S GOT ITS IS ALONG THE LINES
OF BELIEVES TWO YEARS AGO.
AND WE HAD A BUDGET PROPOSAL
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE. TO
CHANGE HOW WE HOW WE PRIORITIZE --
VETERAN APPLICANTS SO WE
PRIORITIZE VETERANS WHO HAVE
SAID YOU PERCENT OR GREATER
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITY
RATINGS WE PRIVATIZE VETERANS
WHO ARE HOMELESS -- TO TRY TO TO
TRY TO FOCUS OUR LIMITED
RESOURCES ON THOSE WHO EITHER
NEED US THE MOST OR SACRIFICE
THE MESSENGER SERVICE.
SO A LOT OF THIS MASTER PLAN --
NEEDS THAT'S BEEN APPROACHES CAN
BE BASED AROUND THAT HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE ALLOCATE OUR RESOURCES
TO THOSE WHO NEED US THE MOST.
NOT NECESSARILY JUST ON WHAT THE
ACTUAL DEMANDES.
DO YOU THINK IS THE COLOR
PROCESSES BEEN EFFECTIVE.
YES ACTUALLY BEEN VERY HELPFUL --
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S REALLY
IT'S REALLY EASY TO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE OUR PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE HOW WE'VE ALWAYS
OPERATED IT'S VERY HELPFUL TO
GETS -- OTHER PEOPLE TELL US
EITHER WHERE WHERE THEY SEE THE
NEED IS IN THERE COMMUNITY WHICH
HAS BEEN FROM.
ELECTED OFFICIALS LOCAL STATE --
FEDERAL -- WHERE?
WHERE THEY SEE THE INDUSTRY
HEADING -- WHICH WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVING FROM -- INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS -- AND ALSO WHERE --
WERE VETERANS IN THE VERNE
COMMUNITY IS GOING AND WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE -- WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVING THAT FROM VARIOUS
VETERANS SERVICE GROUPS AND ALSO
OUR RESIDENTS THEMSELVES.
ON THE POPULATION CERTAINLY
CHANGING SORT OF PAUSE RIGHT NOW
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MIRACLE PLEASE.
COOPER HERE TO YOUR LACKEY IS
ERIN WICKS.
SELECT THE REPLY THAT OTHER
THREE SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM WILL
NOT BE TAKEN UP TODAY.
LET'S BE ABOUT TAKING UP VITAL
ISSUES. ONE THREE SEVENTEEN
NINETY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY SIX LOW MOTION TO APPROVE
THESE ITEMS.
KEVIN MOTIONS SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER HI.
TO LACKEY IS ARIAN WICKS.
THIS WILL TAKE A VITAL ISSUES
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE THESE
ITEMS.
COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY NAZARIAN WICKS
[inaudible]
SHE WAS [inaudible]
SURE. TWELVE FIFTEEN ON THAT --
ONE FOR WE CAN GO TO THAT.
BUT THAT'S FINE.
YEAH SO IT WAS FULL OF ALL GOING
PULLED.
ONLY.
TWENTY FIVE OKAY WILL PULL THAT
ITEM.
OKAY WILL LEAD TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT [inaudible]
CALVET.
CONNECT UP WITH A NUMBER THREE
PROGRAM REVIEW AUDITS
.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SHERRY
GASTINEAU DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
WE ARE REQUESTING AUGMENTATION
OF EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX ONGOING
POSITIONS FOR FISCAL YEAR. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND THEREAFTER TO ESTABLISH
AN PROGRAM REVIEW AN INTERNAL
AUDITS UNITS.
THIS WILL PROVIDE FOR
STANDARDIZATION EFFICIENCIES
IMPROVE INTERNAL CONTROLS.
PROCESSES AND COMPLIANCE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS L.
L..
OUR JACQUI BRASSIERE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR OFFICE HAS
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL REGIONAL
CONCERNS AS MENTIONED IN YOUR
AGENDA I'M GIVEN THAT THIS UNIT
WOULD PRIMARILY BE MONITORING --
COMPLIANCE THIS COULD HELP --
THE ADMINISTRATION OR THE
DEPARTMENT ADDRESS -- SOME OF
THE OVERSIGHT AND REVIEW
CHALLENGES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN PRIOR STATE AUDIT REPORTS
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE STAFF UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE BUT THEY'RE NOT EXCUSE ME.
SITTING IN THE STEPS LISTING
THERE'S NOT BEEN A WORK PLAN
DEVELOPED YET FOR THE AUDIT UNIT.
WITHOUT A WORK PLAN HOUSE THE
AMOUNT OF STAFF NEED TO FOR THE
UNIT DETERMINED.
WELL WE'VE BEEN DOING INTERNAL --
REVIEWS AND LOOKING AT OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AS WELL AND SO
WE'RE GONNA.
GO BACK AND LOOK AT SOME OF THE
AUDITS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE IN
USE THE UNIT TO REVIEW THOSE
[inaudible]
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THE PLAN.
AS A RAINY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AN AUDIT PLAN -- IDEAS FOR
AREAS OF EARLY FOCUS ON THAT --
MOSTLY JUST THE INTERNAL
CONTROLS AND THE PROCESSES WE
HAVE IN PLACE WITH ALL THE
RECENT ON ITS WE'VE HAD -- WILL
BE THE WILL BE ON A US ROLE
INSURING THAT FUTURE LEASES AND
ACTIVITIES THAT HELP BILL.
CONSISTENT WITH STATE LAW.
THOMAS TAKE THAT -- SURE -- SO.
SO THE THE THE RD UNIT I IDEALLY
THE IDEA WILL BE ABLE TO CATCH
VARIOUS ISSUES BEFORE THE CROP
UP OBVIOUSLY IN IN THE CASE OF
LEASES -- THE THE AUDIT BE
UNDERSTOOD AT THE STATE
UNDERSTOOD AND ACTUALLY REPORT
ON THAT -- SOME OF THE PITFALLS
HISTORICALLY SOME THE PROBLEMS
OF COME UP SO THE THE THE AUDIT
UNITS IS GOING TO BE ONE OF ONE
OF THEIR PRIMARY FOCUS IS IS
GOING TO BE ON THE SENATE AND
EARLY RUNNING.
IS GONNA BE MONITORING
COMPLIANCE WITH -- WITH STATE
LAW INTERNAL POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES RELATED TO LEASES --
MAKE SURE THERE AREN'T ANY OTHER
ISSUES THAT THAT COME UP MAKE
YOUR FUTURE AGREEMENTS ARE ARE
IN LINE WITH THAT -- SO SHOULD
BE PRETTY HELPFUL THAT REGARD.
SO THERE TIMELINE FOR COMPLETION
OF THE WORK PLAN.
COULD WE TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST
YEAR SO IT'S IT I GUESS IT'S
FRUSTRATING ON OUR PART YEAH
WHEN WAS TALK ABOUT LAST YEAR IN
HERE WE ARE.
AGAIN.
THE WORK PLAN ESTABLISHED BY
JULY FIRST MUCH LOWER.
OKAY YES AND WE CAN PROVIDE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HELLO OPEN UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM.%
HELLO AGAIN CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
STILL IF YOU'RE NOT IN A CALVET
IS A GOOD STEP WELL LOOK FOR TO
LEARN MORE.
ABOUT THE WORK PLANS TO DO IT --
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET [inaudible]
THEIR MOTION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HERE THIS AFTERNOON
AND JUST WANTED THEIR DUES
MYSELF.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH PRESS AND I
OVERSEE THE MINORITY IN UNDER
REPRESENTED VETERANS DIVISION.
AND I ALSO AND THE STATE
ADVOCATE FOR THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM.
I WAS APPOINTED LAST JANUARY
ORIGINALLY FOR THE MINORITY IN
UNDER REPRESENTED VETERANS
DIVISION.
AND ASSUME THE DUTIES OF THE DVD
PROGRAM IN JULY OF LAST OF LAST
YEAR.
SO I JUST WANTED -- TO POINT OUT
THAT I WANTED -- TO SPEAK TODAY
I'D NOT MYSELF BUT I WAS INVITED
TO SPEAK TODAY REGARDING OUR
PROGRAMS AND OUR DIVISION
DOESN'T.
NECESSARILY HAVE A PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY AS YOU MIGHT
NOTICE -- BUT AND I'M HAPPY
DELIBERATE MORE ABOUT OUR
PROGRAMS AND BEFORE I DO SO I
THINK IT'S FITTING THAT GO AHEAD
AND GIVE SOME FACTS AND
STATISTICS.
ARE REGARDING MINORITY VETERANS
AND UNDER REPRESENTED VETERANS
AND REALLY WHAT IS A UNDER
REPRESENTED VETERAN.
IF THAT IF YOU DON'T MIND SURE
WISH LATELY MR LACKEY HAS JOINED
US [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
SURE SO ON UNDER REPRESENTED
VETERANS DIVISION AND MINORITY
VETS THAT'S AFRICAN AMERICAN
VETS ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER VETS NATIVE AMERICAN
VETS.
WOMEN MINORITY THAT'S LGBT Q.
VETERANS HOMELESS VETERANS AND
ALSO ROLE VETERANS -- SO I THINK
I HAVE EVERYBODY THERE AND ALSO
ERA VETERANS AS WELL
[inaudible]
SO CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE VETERANS ARE ABOUT
ESTIMATED.
ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND POPULATION AND OUR DIVISION
REPRESENTS 43% OF THAT ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION -- ROUGHLY 18% OF
THAT POPULATION.
A VETERANS LIVE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA THIS IS BASED ON SOME
CENSUS DATA.
BACK IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NATION WIDE.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO THE VA --
INFORMATION ON THE MINORITY
VETERANS SUPPORT. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OVER 44% OF OUR
NATION'S.
BLOCKING HISPANIC VETERANS ARE
HOMELESS AND A LARGE POPULATION
OF THAT BELONGS HERE TO
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE LARGEST
NUMBERS OF VETERANS HEARIN
CALIFORNIAN ALSO MINORITY
VETERANS AND UNDERREPRESENTED
VETERANS.
AND A LARGE PART OF THAT --
POPULATION ALSO -- LONGS
UNFORTUNATELY TO CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO NATIVE AMERICANS WE
HAVE THREE TIMES THE NUMBER
THREE TO TWO TIMES A NUMBER.
OF NATIVE AMERICAN VETERANS
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES WHICH
IS NEARLY.
TWENTY UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND
NATIVE AMERICAN VETERANS.
AND ALSO CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
THE LARGEST POPULATION IT LGBT
Q. VETERANS.
WHICH IS ESTIMATED AROUND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
LGBT Q. VETERANS.
THAT CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
AND ALSO THE US MILITARY IS THE
LARGEST EMPLOYER TO TRANSIT
BETTER ENDS IN THE WORLD.
BUT MANY OF THESE VETERANS --
ARE NOT CONNECTED TO THEIR
BENEFITS AND SERVICES.
AND TWO MORE ARE STATISTICS THE
POPULATION OF WOMEN MINORITY
VETERANS NATIONWIDE INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE.
AND WE HAVE THE FASTEST GROWTH
THEY HAVE THE FASTEST GROWING
NUMBER OF POPULATION.
A VETERAN DVD A DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS OWNERS AND ALSO BETTER
BUSINESS OWNERS.
AND 70% OF THOSE -- BETTER
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE.
AB HIRED -- VETERANS AS PART OF
THE WORK FORCE SO IT'S JUST NOT
THE VETERAN.
BUSINESS OWNERS THEMSELVES BUT
ALSO 70% OF THOSE -- 7070% OR
MORE THEY HIRE VETERANS IS AS
PART OF THEIR WORK FORCE AND
THEY ALSO HAVE A SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURSHIP TYPE OF
BUSINESS MODEL.
COMMUNITY.
TYPE OF BUSINESS MODEL.
AND THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN OUR DIVISION FLETCHER
DEVELOP LAST YEAR -- NUMBER ONE
IN WAS THE FIRST TO BE --
ESTABLISH AND YOU ASK IS THE
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP PROGRAM
ASSISTING VETERANS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS -- TOWARDS THEIR PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP [inaudible]
WE ALSO.
HAVE THE DEPORTED VETERANS
PROGRAM.
AND ASSISTING VETERANS ALSO IN
LIMBO AT THE DETENTION CENTERS
AS WELL AND TRYING TO GET
MEDICAL AND SCRIPT SINCE TO
THOSE VETERANS SOMETIMES CAUGHT
UP IN THE SYSTEM.
WE HAVE THE TRIBAL VETERANS
ADVOCATE PROGRAM.
AND THEN FOURTH WE HAVE THE
LGBTQ INCLUSION PROGRAM WHICH
KICKS OFF THE SUMMER AND THEN.
FIFTH WE HAVE THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE.
PROGRAM THAT WE OVERSEE WITHIN
OUR DIVISION.
AND I'M HAPPY.
TO ELABORATE MORE ON THOSE
PROGRAMS ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU L. L.
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
I'LL JUST MAKE A BRIEF STATEMENT
THAT -- IF CALVET HAS THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED POSITIONS IT DOES SEEM
TO ME THAT.
ABOUT BEEF IN THE CAPACITY IN
THIS AREA.
DOUBLING AND TRIPLING AND JUST
ADDING SOME ADDITIONAL HEAD
COUNT WOULD MAKE SENSE I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IS MY TWO CENTS
OR SOMETHING I WOULD SUPPORT.
A FURTHER DOWN THE LINE.
SO I'LL FOLLOW UP ON THAT SO
SINCE YOU'RE IT.
A SINGLE PERSON -- HOUSE LITTLE
STAFFING ADEQUATE TO ENSURE THAT
THESE VETERANS ARE BEING
CONNECTED WITH A FEDERAL
BENEFITS.
I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT SURF.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE -- TO DEDICATED
STAFF RECENTLY FOR THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROGRAM.
AND NOT -- WE JUST HIRED OUR
FIRST A DV PROGRAM MANAGER THIS
JANUARY AND OUR DVD BUSINESS
ANALYSTS IS FEBRUARY.
OKAY SO JUST ADDED JUST FOR
SOLELY FOR THE TV B. E. PROGRAM
SIR NOT FOR THE MINORITY IN
UNDER REPRESENTED VETERANS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I ONE OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT
DELICIOUS BECOMES ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FREDERICK OR METAL ON THE STATE
COMMANDER FOR THE AMERICAN GI
FORUM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO THE CO OF THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMANDERS COUNSEL
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE REALLY.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS DEPUTY
SECRETARY A LIST BUT AS AND THAT
SHE DOES NEED HELP AND WHEN IT
SAYS THAT THERE'S TWO TO THREE
MEETINGS A MONTH THAT SHE GOALS.
I THINK YOU CAN SEE THAT SHE
GOES TO MORE MAYBE DOUBLE THAT.
AND SO WE'RE REALLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF AS MINORITY VETERANS THAT
THAT -- SHE GETS MORE HELP AND
MAYBE GET A COUPLE OF PEOPLE TO
HELP HER WITH THE REST OF OF THE
JOB THAT SHE HAS TO DO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
HELLO CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
MINORITY UNDER REPRESENTED
VETERANS ARE IMPORTANT GROUP OF
VETERANS A SOMETIMES SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS THEY'RE NOT
CONNECTED WITH THE FEDERAL
BENEFITS.
THEY HAVE EARNED A READY ESERVER.
AS A RESULT FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT
COULD BE HELPING HIS VETERANS IN
OUR STATE ARE LEFT ON THE TABLE.
WE'RE CONTINUING TO EVALUATE
THIS AREA MAY HAVE PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE STAFF TO BETTER SURE
THE STATE IS MEETING THE NEEDS
OF THESE VETERANS.
AS RECOMMENDATIONS HOLD OPEN ALL
THIS OPEN.
NEXT WE WANT OUT OF LIFE -- PART
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING STAFFING
AUGMENTATION [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
MORRIS I'M THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING -- SO THE
BOARD DID YOU KNOW OF REPRESENTS
CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
LICENSEES PERHAPS.
THE LARGEST HEALING ARTS BOARDS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AS YOU KNOW THE BOARD IS A VERY
COMPLEX ENTITY.
AND NOT ONLY DO WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERSIGHT OF
NO FORCED ME IN LICENSEES BUT
AND NURSING BUT ALSO.
A HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE PLUS
NURSING PROGRAMS.
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CHAU OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
THE BOARD HAS RECEIVED IMMENSE
SCRUTINY OVER ITS -- ENFORCEMENT
AND LICENSING -- OVERSIGHT
HOWEVER SINCE THEN.
THE BOARD IS WORKING VERY
CLOSELY.
WITH BOB DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND OTHER -- AGENCIES TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE NOW ONLY
UPDATE IT.
OUR INTERNAL PROCESSES BUT ALSO
INCREASE OUR AND TRAINING
EFFORTS AND RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
AS WELL -- BOB SO.
WE RESPECTFULLY WE'RE REQUESTING.
THE SIXTY SEVEN POSITIONS IN IN
THE IN THE B. C. P. -- WE DON'T
IS VERY LARGE REQUEST.
BUT CHAO WILL BE VERY CONFIDENT
AS WE RACED OUR FEES THAT WERE
ABLE.
TO RESPOND TO THE CONSUMERS --
YOU KNOW WHAT WITH THE AND
NUMBER STAFF REQUESTED.
THANK YOU L. L..
HOW INTERESTING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS?
BUT IT'S ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE -- WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT.
CALCULUS PUBLIC COMMENT -- THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING HAS
FOUND SIGNIFICANT AS FACELIFT
CAN SALAS IS.
IN THE PAST NO FOR THE VISION OF
THE STAFF WILL HELP.
WILL BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO HELPING A BETTER
SERVER PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AS A FATHER OF OUR IN.
THE ONE YEAR THIS MONTH -- LOOK
FORWARD -- TO HELPING.
THEIR PRISONERS IN BOARD.
DEALS ON THESE ISSUES SO -- THE
RECOGNITION TO APPROVE HIS
BUDGET IS THERE A MOTION.
WELL MOTIONS SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE COOPER HI.
TWO LACKEY.
THE SYRIAN WICKS.
CAN AS WELL UNDER SIX
CONSECUTIVE RECORD THANK YOU
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD AND VARADA
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED [inaudible]
GOOD ACTORS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANICE
AND TALKING ON THE CHIEF FISCAL
OFFICER AT THE DEPARTMENT -- THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY --
REQUEST FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
IN TWENTY FOUR AND A HALF
POSITIONS TO THE FOLLOWING FIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE AN INVESTIGATIVE
OFFICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
THE FIRST BEING BUSINESS
SERVICES IN FISCAL OPERATIONS WE
REQUEST SEVEN POSITIONS AND
FUNDING ON A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS. TO ADDRESS
SIGNIFICANT WORK WHAT INCREASES
ENHANCED AUDIT REQUIREMENTS AN
EXCEEDINGLY COMPLEX ACCOUNTING
PROCESSES.
THESE RESOURCES WILL RESULT IN A
MORE TIMELY RECONCILIATION OF
OUR ACCOUNTING RECORDS FASTER
PROCESSING OF INVOICES AND
BETTER REPORTING OF EXPENDITURES
AND REVENUE INFORMATION.
THE SECOND OFFICE WERE ASKING
FOR THE AUGMENTATIONS FOR LEGAL
AFFAIRS DIVISION THAT REQUEST
THREE YEARS OF LIMITED TERM
FUNDING TO SUPPORT SIX ATTORNEYS
AND TO SUPPORT STAFF. TO CREATE
A DEDICATED REGULATION UNIT TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
TIMELINESS OF REGULATION
PACKAGES AND TO INCREASE OUTPUT
TO MEET DEMAND.
THE THIRD OFFICE IS THE DIVISION
OF INVESTIGATION WE'RE
REQUESTING FOUR AND A HALF
INVESTIGATOR POSITIONS WITH
FINDING ALONG WITH MEDICAL
CONSULTING FUNDING TO ADDRESS
INVESTIGATOR CASELOAD WORKLOAD
AND THAT THE AGING OF CASES.
THIS WILL RESULT IN A MORE
TIMELY AND EFFICIENT AND HIGH
QUALITY INVESTORS KATORI WORK.
THESE COSTS ARE DIRECTLY FUNDED
BY THE BOARDS IMPERO IS THAT USE
THE SERVICES.
THE FOURTH OFFICE BE IN THE
OFFICE OF HUMAN RESOURCES THAT
REQUESTS FORTY SIX THOUSAND TO
FUND THE CONVERSION OF THREE
PERMANENT INTERMITTENT POSITIONS
INTO PERMANENT FULL TIME. TO
ADDRESS RECRUITMENT AND RETURN
TO WORK WORKLOAD.
THIS WILL MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
SERVICE LEVELS WITHIN OUR OFFICE
OF HUMAN RESOURCES.
AND THE LAST FIFTH OFFICE IS THE
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
EXAMINATION SERVICES WERE
REQUEST TO POSITIONS AND FUNDING
TO MEET THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
FOR DEVELOPING MAINTAINING AND
BIT INVALIDATING OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING EXAMINATIONS.
SO WE THAT'S THAT'S OUR PROPOSAL
A WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN HERE RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU L. L..
SO AS YOU HEARD THERE ARE
MULTIPLE COMPONENTS OF THIS --
PROPOSAL SUMMER FUNDED BASED ON
USAGE SO SOMETHING LIKE AN
HOURLY RATE SOME OF THEM ARE
FUNDED BASED ON WHAT'S CALLED
PER RAT I WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A
WAY TO SPREAD COST OUT.
ON TYPICALLY IT'S DONE BY
POSITION COUNTS OF THE BOARDS IN
EUROS PAY MORE IF THEY HAVE MORE
POSITIONS LIKE THAT THEY HAVE
YOUR POSITIONS.
SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING REJECTING
THE COMPONENTS THAT ARE FUNDED
ON A PRO RATA BASIS THERE REALLY
TWO REASONS FOR THAT THE FIRST
IS THAT WE THINK THAT IT'S
GENERALLY PREMATURE TO DO THIS --
THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT LAST
YEAR IN THE BUDGET THE
LEGISLATURE -- PROVIDED FUNDING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO DO YOU --
SOME BUSINESS PROCESS REVIEWS OF
THEIR PRO RATA FUNDED SERVICES
AND THEY'VE ONLY COMPLETED ONE A
PORTION OF THOSE REVIEWS MOST OF
THOSE REVIEWS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
COMPLETED -- SO WE THINK THAT --
IT WOULD BE BETTER TO WAIT UNTIL
THOSE ARE COMPLETED.
AND THE SECOND.
REASON IS THAT WE THINK IN SOME
AREAS THAT WE'RE GOOD
JUSTIFICATION IS LACKING --
EXAMPLE A THERE WAS A TRANSITION
OF ONE OF THE BUREAU'S WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OUT -- TWO
SEPARATE DEPARTMENT -- AND
THOUGH THERE SHOULD BE SOME
ASSOCIATED REDUCTION IN THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH --
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THAT
BUREAU WHICH YOU DON'T THINK
IT'S FULLY REFLECTED IN THE
PROPOSAL ADDITIONALLY I'VE YOU
HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS NEW
REGULATORY -- REVIEW UNIT WITHIN
THE CA -- AND THE WORKLOAD
JUSTIFICATION DOESN'T FULLY TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THAT CURRENTLY
THERE ARE SOME STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE REVIEWING --
REGULATORY -- SUBMISSIONS FROM
BUREAUS IMPORTS AND SO WE THINK
THAT THOSE ARE SOME OTHER
REASONS FOR REJECTING -- THE
PAROTID COMPONENT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
KITCHEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE REQUEST
AS PROPOSED AS DCA HAD NOTED --
THE RESOURCES FOR THAT A
DEDICATED REGULATIONS UNIT AND
THE ACCOUNTING FISCAL SERVICES.
ARE REQUESTED A LIMóN TERM
BASIS AND THESE ARE THE OFFICES
THAT ARE FUNDED ON A PRO RATA
BASIS -- WE THINK THAT'S
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS MORE
IMMEDIATE ISSUES -- AND WORKLOAD
INCREASES WHILE LYING FOR THE
SUBSEQUENT EVALUATION OF ONGOING
RESOURCE NEEDS BASED ON THE
ORGANIZATIONAL MANAGEMENT
REVIEWS -- WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT FISCAL HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
AND IMPACT TO THE DEPARTMENTS
PROCESS SEES AND TO YOUR LIMITED
TERM RESOURCES ARE NEEDED -- TO
HELP ADDRESS THE THE INCREASE TO
WORK WITH THE PROMISED SPERRIN
SEEING.
WERE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE
REGULATIONS UNIT BECAUSE THERE'S
A CAPACITY ISSUE -- THE EXISTING
STAFF SIMPLY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT VOLUME OF
REGULATIONS INCLUDING INCREASED
WORKLOAD FROM AB -- TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT WE THINK A
DEDICATED UNIT ONE PROVE THE
QUALITY AND ALSO REDUCED
EXISTING TIMELINES. FOR
REGULATIONS WHICH HAS BEEN A
CONCERN OF THE BOARDS -- AND HAS
ALSO -- AS WELL IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL.
THE REGULATIONS ISSUE -- WHAT IS?
THE SORRY A IS THE PROVIDER
WORKING GROUP'S HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR THE ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT REVIEWS.
AND WE KNOW THAT ESTABLISHING
THIS DEDICATED UNITS OF
CONSISTENT WITH THE RECENT
REPORT THAT ACTUALLY CAME OUT --
BASED ON THEIR FIRST
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE MANAGEMENT
REVIEW -- AND THEN LASTLY JUST
WANTED TO KIND OF SPEAK TO THE
LA WAS COMMENT ON THE RESOURCES
HAVING NOT BEEN REDUCED FOR THE
BEER OF REAL ESTATE.
SHIFTING TO A DEPARTMENT THERE
WERE TWO PROPOSALS LAST YEAR THE
ACTUALLY REDUCED UP -- THAT WERE
APPROVED TO BEGIN REDUCING
RESOURCES -- FOREVER SHIFTING
THAT THE BEAR OUT.
THANK YOU IT COMES IN COMMITTEE
A QUESTION FOR MR.
TO THANK YOU.
LAST YEAR I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
MY OFFICE AS WELL AS A STATEWIDE
COALITION WORKING WITH THE CA
AND THE BOARDS AND BUREAUS.
ON THE TOPIC OF HOW DCA REFORMS
THE WAY WHICH CRIMINAL RECORDS
ARE CONSIDERED TO THE LICENSING
APPLICATION PROCESS --
SPECIFICALLY -- THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A LAW THAT GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED THAT SAID THAT NON
VIOLENT OFFENSES THAT WERE
LONGER THAN SEVEN YEARS -- THERE
WERE UNRELATED TO A LICENSE
SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED AND AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE DCA TO PROMULGATE ABOUT
FORTY REGUATORY PACKAGES BY
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY SO
THIS BILL REQUIRES ALMOST EVERY
BOARD OR BUREAU TO UPDATE THE
REGULATIONS.
WHEN WE WENT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THE AGENCY
PUT QUITE A LARGE PRICE TAG ON?
THIS BILL AND APPROPRIATIONS AND
IT HUSBANDSIGNED -- AND WE
DON'T SEE ANY MENTION OF IT IN
EITHER THIS ITEM OR THE THE ITEM
THAT I SB HELD -- INVOLVING
TWELVE OTHER BILLS THAT WILL
HAVE REGULATIONS PROMULGATED SO
I WANTED TO GET SOME RESPONSE
AND WHITE THIS WAS NOT CALLED
OUT.
SURE ASSEMBLYMEMBER -- TO
DEMOCRATS ROMERO DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATION AT THE DEPARTMENT --
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT I
WAS BUILT INTO THE REGULATIONS
UNIT -- THE THE GOAL THE
REGULATIONS UNIT IS OBVIOUSLY TO
MEET THE DEMAND AS A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS MENTIONED ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE REGULATIONS
PROMULGATED PER YEAR -- BUT THE
DIVISION CURRENTLY HAS A
CAPACITY TO GET UP ABOUT -- TO
PROMULGATE ABOUT FIFTY
REGULATIONS UNITS -- REGULATION
PACKETS PER YEAR PER YEAR --
THAT WAS WAS BILL -- TEN THE
CHALLENGE FOR THE DEPARTMENT IS
THAT -- WITHOUT THE REGULATIONS
UNIT -- PROGRAMS MAY HAVE TO
MAKE THE DECISION OF CHOOSING
WHETHER TO IMPLEMENT TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT OR CURRENT EXISTING
REGULATIONS PACKETS WE BELIEVE
THE REGULATIONS UNIT WITH A
DEDICATED UNIT THAT FOCUS SOLELY
ON REGULATIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
MEET THE CAPACITY ISSUE.
AND IMPLEMENT TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT OUT OF MY COLLEAGUE RYAN
IS THE DEPUTY -- TO DIRECTOR OF
THE LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION HE
COULD SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE IF
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COULD.
WHAT YOU ARE TO SPENDING THE
COST OF THAT TO BE?
AND HOW WILL I KNOW THAT IF WE
SEND THIS MONEY TO GUYS IT'LL
ACTUALLY BE USED FOR THAT
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID IT'S GOING
TO BE A TRADE OFF AND WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN AS THEIR NUMBER OF DCA
DEPARTMENTS.
OR BUREAUS AND BOARDS THAT HAD
OPPOSED THE BILL AND I SUSPECT
MAY NOT BE.
ITCHING TO IMPLEMENT THIS.
SO THE THE THE COST THAT WE HAVE --
OBVIOUSLY AS WE AS WE LOOK INTO
THE REGULATIONS UNIT WE HAVE A
IF I HAVE THE THE NUMBERS
CORRECTLY -- ONE SECOND IT'S ONE
POINT SIX SEVEN MILLION IN --
NINETEEN NINETEEN TWENTY IT IS A
THREE THE THE POSITIONS ARE
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM SO WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE
ARE HITTING THE SWEET SPOT SO TO
SPEAK IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
POSITIONS THAT WE'RE SUGGESTS --
ABER.
SUGGESTING -- AND AFTER THREE
YEARS HOPEFULLY AFTER WE
IMPLEMENT TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT AND MEET THE DEMANDS OF
THE THE BACKLOG THAT WE CAN COME
BACK TO LEGISLATURE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALL HAVE FOUND THE
RIGHT APPROACH.
SO THE PRICE TAG THE YOUR
DEPARTMENT PLACED ON THIS BILL
WAS TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND SO.
THE DEPARTMENT THAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING CREATING YOU'RE NOT
EVEN SEND ALL OF THAT MONEY IS
GOING TO GO TO IMPLEMENTING THIS
NEW.
PROGRAM RIGHT.
COULD I JUST GET SOME MORE
CLARITY ON HOW MUCH WHAT
FRACTION THESE RESOURCES ARE
ACTUALLY AND GO. TO MAKING SURE
THAT YOU ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
WHAT IS NOW STATE LAW SURE HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU -- AFTER
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING OKAY I'M
NOT PREPARED TO VOTE ON THIS
TODAY.
UNTIL I GET SOME ANSWERS TO THAT.
NOT AVAILABLE MISTER CHOOSE
QUESTIONS FAR AS THE THE CRIMES
THAT THIS SERIES NON VIOLENT
CRIMES AND SEE A LIST OF THOSE
IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE NUMBER OF
CRIMES THAT ARE.
CONSIDERED NOT ANSWERS
NONVIOLENT.
THAT IN MY PERSONAL OPINION I
BELIEVE WE'RE DOING THE PUBLIC
OPINION.
ARE SERIOUS AND VIOLENT SO.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A LIST OF OF
THOSE CRIMES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ADDRESSING HERE.
WITH THAT.
SURE I WOULD I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THAT AND IN A TIMELY MANNER.
SO THE CITY COULD HAVE BY THE
END OF THE MONTH FOR HELEN.
I BELIEVE WE COULD.
COME UP WITH THAT AT AS WE ARE
SO WE ARE SIMPLY IMPLEMENTING
THE BILL THAT WAS PASSED AT LAST
YEAR YOU'RE.%
YOU'RE REFERRING TO AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY OR IS THAT CORRECT
YES WE CAN PROVIDE THAT FOR YOU
SURE -- L. L. -- THE ALREADY BUT
IT ALREADY OKAY I LOST TRACK OF
THAT -- ANYMORE QUESTION
COMMITTEE.
GOING UP A PUBLIC COMMENT.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT --
SO I KNOW THE LA -- TOUCHED ON
IT.
BRIEFLY BUT I SELL WITH ME LAST
WITH MR.
TO IN THE BUDGET REQUEST WAS
PREPARED BEFORE.
THE REVIEW WAS COMPLETED.
SO WE'RE HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN TO
ALLOW MORE TIME FOR DISCUSSIONS
THEY CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT ITEM ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
BUSINESS MOTIVATION PLAN IN
BREEZES SYSTEM UPDATE
MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THIS BCP WITH YOU.
MY NAME IS SEAN O'CONNOR AND
WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS OFFICE OF INFORMATION
SERVICES.
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PHARMACY
AND BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY OR TWO
OF THE SEVENTEEN PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY PROCEEDING THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION INITIATIVE.
THE BCP BEFORE YOU TODAY REQUEST
ONE YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING IN
THE AMOUNT OF FIVE HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FUND. FOR
TOTAL STAFF POSITIONS TO FOR THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY TO FOR THE
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY.
THESE RESOURCES WILL ENGAGE IN
CRITICAL PLANNING EFFORTS TO
TRANSITION TO A NEW INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM AS PART OF
THAT EACH PROGRAM'S INDIVIDUAL
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN
WE REQUEST SUPPORT OF THE
SPECIES P. RESPECTFULLY AND
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
L. L..
SO WE'RE NOT READING ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE VC PEAS UNDER
CONSIDERATION TODAY WE DID HAVE
SOME LARGER COMMENTS RELATED TO
THE BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN
AND THIS IS BASICALLY -- THE
PLAN FOR THE REMAINING BOARDS IN
BUREAUS THAT WERE ON THE
ORIGINAL BREEZE PROJECT BUT THEN --
SUBSEQUENTLY BREEZE WAS
TERMINATED AND SO THESE ARE THE
BOARDS IN BUREAUS THAT ARE
REMAINING AND THEY STILL NEED
SOME I. T. SOLUTION -- SO OUR
COMMENTS GENERALLY -- FOLLOW
THAT THE TRAIN OF THOUGHT THAT
THE BASICALLY THE DEPARTMENTS
APPROACH HAS BEEN TO ALLOW THESE
BOARDS IN BUREAU TO KIND OF MOVE
AT THEIR OWN PACE THESE RELEASED
THREE ENTITIES -- SO SOME OF
THEM ARE MOVING MORE QUICKLY
SOME OF THEM ARE MOVING LESS
QUICKLY THE RATIONALE FOR THAT
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT IS
BASICALLY THAT SOME OF THESE
ENTITIES -- ARE HAVE MORE
ORGANIZATIONAL READY NESTS
CURRENTLY TODAY -- AND ARE
PREPARED TO MOVE FASTER THAN
OTHERS -- SO THAT MAKES SENSE TO
SOME DEGREE BUT THERE ARE SOME
REPERCUSSIONS -- SOME OF THESE
ENTITIES ARE AS A RESULT MOVING
MORE SLOWLY THAN OTHERS AS YOU
MIGHT EXPECT -- AND THE CURRENT --
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION REPORT
THAT WAS RELEASED IN DECEMBER
REFLECT THAT SOME ENTITIES
CURRENTLY HAVE KIND OF T. B. D.
AS THEIR AS THEIR CURRENT
TIMELINE OR TIME LINES THAT ARE
SEVERAL YEARS OFF.
AND SO WE THINK THIS MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE CHALLENGING FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE PROJECT AND
IT RAISES SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
REALLY WHAT THE APPROPRIATE ROLE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT IS IN TERMS
OF OVERSEEING THESE PROJECTS AND
HOW MUCH THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
TAKE A LEADERSHIP.
ROLE INSTEAD OF MAKING SURE
THESE BOARDS IN BUREAUS-- MOVE
AT AT AT AT SORT OF RELATIVELY
QUICK PACE I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED LANGUAGE
IN THE PAST THAT REQUIRED THIS
REPORT AND REQUIRED UPDATES ON
THESE TIME LINES.
I'M SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THERE
WAS INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
THESE ENTITIES GOT THE
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS THAT THEY
NEEDED IN A TIMELY FASHION -- SO
OUR RECOMMENDATION IS TO HAVE
THE CA REPORTED HEARING SUCH AS
THIS ONE AS WELL AS THE RELEVANT
BOARDS AND BUREAUS.
I'M REALLY ONLINE.
THE DEPARTMENT'S RATIONALE FOR
THEIR APPROACH OF IN IN TERMS OF
HAVING THESE BOARDS IN EUROS
MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS -- AS
WELL AS AS THE SPECIFIC REASON
SOMEBODY'S ENTITIES NOW HAVE T.
B. D. AS THEIR TIME LINES AND WE
THINK THIS WILL HELP THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN A WAY WHETHER IT'S
COMFORTABLE WITH THE APPROACH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT TAKING OR IF
THE DIP AT THE LEGISLATURE AND
WANTED TO DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT
TO TAKE A MORE HANDS ON APPROACH.
TO TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THESE
BOARDS IN BUREAUS -- GET IT
SOLUTIONS.
ON A FOLLOW UP ON ILLEGALS
COMMENTS YOUR DC IS THE MOTHER
SHIP.
IS ALL YOUR KIDS.
THE LETTER OWN DEVICES BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IT'S IT'S REALLY OPEN
ENDED.
WHEN THEY'RE GONNA DO THIS SO WE
STARTED IT SO I MEAN AS WE SIT
HERE TODAY?
THERE IS NO DEADLINE FOR THESE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS FINISH
CORRECT -- THERE'S ESTIMATED
TIME TO COMPLETE THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE ORIGINAL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PLAN -- THOSE WERE
UPDATING THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PLAN -- AS LA -- MENTIONED --
SOME OF THE TIME LINES APPEAR TO
TO TO NEED TO BE UPDATED AGAIN
SO RAPID PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION I'M ALSO PREPARED TO
SPEAKING GIVE YOU A STATUS
UPDATE OF WHERE ALL SEVENTEEN
ARE SENSITIVE RIGHT NOW SO RIGHT
NOW WHAT IS ARE.
THAT YOU'RE FOR THE STOUT
TIMELINE RIGHT NOW -- FURTHEST
OUT TIMELINE AS FAR AS
COMPLETION OF ON ENTIRE COMPLETE
OF THE ENTIRE PROJECT.
WILL OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE GOT
DIFFERENT BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
WITH DIFFERENT TIMELINES.
HI I'M I GUESS I'M ASKING WHAT
IS YOUR WHOSE ALONG A TIME LINE
RIGHT NOW -- I BELIEVE IT WAS
ENDING ABLE IN -- THAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE I THINK
IT'S TWENTY TWENTY ONE I BELIEVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS THE LATEST
PLANNED LAUNCH DATE RIGHT THE I
MEAN SITTING UP HERE.
WE WE STARTED IN EIGHTEEN IN
LONG BEFORE THAT.
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE TILL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE I MEAN I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE RIGHT NOW
IT'S NOT THE WAY YOU RUN
ORGANIZATION ESPECIALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT IS DRAGGING OUT.
I THINK EVERYBODY NEW LABEL AND
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN AND
GRANTED YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS THE MAKE
UPS.
BUT A SOME POINT IT'S GOT TO
COME TOGETHER.
IN SETTLE A IN AND AND FUTURE
COMMITTEE I THINK MIKE MY
COLLEAGUES A C. MISTERS CHOOSE
EXPRESSION ON THIS.
THAT THAT JUST DOESN'T WORK FOR
US HERE.
SO I'M JUST TELL YOU I'M NOT
GONNA I'M NOT SUPPORTIVE OF THIS.
UNLESS WE GET SOME STRICTER TIME
WHETHER GUIDELINES EVEN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THERE TO
PHONE TO DO THAT -- SO SO WHAT
POINT DO WE GOT TO CUT THE
SIPHON OFF.
IT'S NOT JUST A FREE FLOW OF
CASH.
IS THIS NEEDS TO BE DONE --
FINANCED.
THANK YOU -- OVERALL THE GOAL IS --
FOR TO GET THE REMAINING --
BOARDS EMBARRASSED OFF THE
LEGACY SYSTEMS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE -- BUT ULTIMATELY THE
PLAN NEEDS THE BOARD IMPAIR ROSE
ENGAGEMENT AND ADEQUATE
RESOURCES WE KNOW THAT THE IN
THE AGENDA THAT LEO.
IDENTIFIED CONCERNS WITH JUST
FIVE OF THE BOARDS AND HEROES --
AND TERMS OF THE TIME LINES AND
THREE OF THOSE BOARDS
EMBARRASSED OF ACTUALLY SUMMIT
OF APRIL ONE SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS WERE RESOURCES TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES -- IN --
NINETEEN IN -- NINETEEN TWENTY
AND WILL ALSO NOTE THAT THE
PLANNED LAUNCH DATES FOR THOSE --
THREE ENTITIES ARE VERY CLOSE OR
IN SOME CASES ACTUALLY AHEAD OF
THE ESTIMATED TIME LINES INITIAL
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN REPORT.
QUESTION.
MISTER.
TO MY PLEASURE MISTER CHAIRS
INITIAL COMMENTS AND HE'S HEARD
ME -- SAY WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY
BUT CERTAINLY FOR THE NEWER
MEMBERS ON OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THIS IS A
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT EVERY FEW
WEEKS HEARS ABOUT ANOTHER.
I. T. PROJECT THAT HAS BEEN A
BUREAUCRATIC DISASTER AND THIS
IS YET ANOTHER ONE AND LET ME
JUST.
SUMMARIZE -- THIS IS A PROJECT
THAT STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE WITH A PRODUCT WITH A
APPROVED BUDGET OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
IT STRETCH FOR YEARS -- THE
PROJECT COSTS ROSE TO NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN THE
FINAL RELEASE WAS CANCELED AND
IT IS NOW. 201-9 AND WE'RE NOW
HEARING THAT ASPECTS OF THIS
PROJECT WHAT FINISH UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE LET ME ASK WHICH OF
YOU IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE DATE.
THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE DATE WAS
WORKED -- IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE THE BOARD.
THE BOARD SO -- WITHIN THE BIZ
MODERNIZATION PLAN AND THOUGH I
CAN'T RECALL WHICH SPECIFIC
BOARD THAT WAS -- AT THE TIME OF
THAT ALL THE SCHEDULES BASED ON
TWO SPECIFIC THINGS OF PROBABLY
MORE GRANULAR.
DETAILS BUT THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE ASSIGNED TO THIS
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION WHICH IS
WORKING WITH ALL OF THE BOARDS
TO IDENTIFY BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS.
OF A CURRENT BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT -- AS WELL AS THEIR
OPERATIONAL NEEDS WHEN WE BEGAN
CREATED THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PLAN WE BOTH SCHEDULED
BASED ON THE RESOURCE AS WELL AS
THE OPERATIONAL NEEDS.
OF EACH BOREDOM BUREAU.
SO THAT CREATED THE INITIAL
SCHEDULE -- I WILL.
SAY THAT I WE ABSOLUTELY HEARD
YOUR FRUSTRATION IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS WITH EXACTLY WHAT YOU
JUST SAID AND I WILL STATE I
WILL SAY AND ASSERT THAT.
THIS STRATEGY THOUGH I DO -- I
DO RECOGNIZE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
TO BE A CONSIDERABLY FAR OUT.
IS.
A STRATEGIC -- POSITIVE STRATEGY.
TO SUCCESSFUL IT PROJECTS AND I
WILL SEE SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS
PROJECTS WHICH SAYS SIX I'M
SORRY SIR SUCCESSFUL WHAT SECTOR.
SUCCESSFUL IN THE BUREAUCRATIC.
HELL HOLE THAT YOU HAVE CREATED
[inaudible]
WITH THIS.
THERE'S NO PROJECT IN ANY SECTOR
THAT SIX YEARS LATER.
IT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE TO HAVE A
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE DAY RIGHT.
I'M SORRY MAYBE IN YOUR MIND.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME STARTED NO
NINE IS VINCE BCP'S.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING I MEAN SO
IT'S NOT YOU CAN COME BACK YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
THE SAME FRUSTRATION SO.
GIVE US RESTORATION LAST YEAR
AND NOT MUCH HAS CHANGED WE ARE
A YEAR LATER.
AND IF WE LET IT CONTINUE AS IT
IS THE SAME THING IN TWENTY
TWENTY SO I AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED THE BRAKES ON RIGHT
NOW YOU GUYS RESPONSIBLE YOU'RE
IN CHARGE.
THE SHIP START TO THE TOP SO I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE ISSUES ARE.
BUT WE CONTINUALLY FUND YOU FOR
YOUR REQUEST ME MORE MONEY WE
NEED THIS WE HAVE BEEN VERY
ACCOMMODATING IN THAT.
BUT AT SOME POINT SOLICITED
APPEAR IN THE ROOM SAY HEY YOU
KNOW WHAT TIME OUT.
GET YOUR ACT TOGETHER.
AND I'M NOT LAYING BLAME ON YOU
IS JUST SYSTEMIC.
BUT IT'S GOT TO BE FIXED AND I I
MEAN MR CHOOSE BEEN.
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
WITH THIS IS THE I. T..
I BILLS COMMITTEE FIVE YEARS
SINCE I CAME IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND I THINK COMMITTEE AND IT'S
THE SAME.
STUFF THE SAME B. S. AND IT'S
JUST IT'S JUST I'M DONE.
THERE ARE NO MORE EXCUSES.
NO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
GET TOGETHERS IT.
IT'S NOT THAT COMPLICATED.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT?
SO I JUST I MEAN WITH SOME
STARTLING MONEY AT NOT DOING
ANYMORE.
SORRY MR TO NóI.
HI I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
WERE WERE ON THE SAME PAGE ON
THIS BECAUSE EVERY YEAR WE'VE
APPROVED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF IT PROJECTS AND WE'RE
NOT SEEN ANY FRUITION IN FACT IT
SEEMS LIKE.
THE DATES THAT WERE SET KEEP
STRETCHING SO I THINK FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IF YOU THINK IT'S
STRATEGIC A STRATEGIC IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO AVOID THE OVERSIGHT OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT I HAVE SAID IN PRIOR YEARS
THAT THERE IS GOING TO COME A
POINT WHERE I CAN APPROVE THESE
ANYMORE AND I FEEL LIKE.
WE'VE HIT THAT POINT SO -- I
HEAR EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING IT
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF
BUREAUCRATIC.
MUMBLE JUMBLE THAT.
FRANKLY I DON'T THINK CAN
EXPLAIN TO THE PUBLIC HOW WE
SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I DON'T THINK IF YOU HAD THIS
PROJECT TO DO IN ANY OTHER
SECTOR THAT THERE IT WOULD BE
ACCEPTED TO SAY THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE IS.
A IS A DATE THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO GET THINGS DONE IN IT THE
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO CHANGE
THREE TIMES.
BY THAT DATE SO -- I CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW IT IS THAT WE
SHOULD BE EXPECTED HAVE FAITH
THAT THE SELECTION AND GET ON I
UNDERSTAND -- THE THINGS I
WANTED TO RESPOND -- THESE
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
FOR THE SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN GROSS --
ART WE'RE WE'RE ATTACKING EMERGE
WRITING THEM AT SEVENTEEN
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS AS WAS --
NOTED IN LESSONS LEARNED IN THE
BREEZE PROJECT AS WELL AS THE
STATE BOARD OF OF AUDIT
SUGGESTED THAT A ONE OF THEIR
FINDINGS WAS THAT WE ADDRESS --
THEIR NEEDS ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS AND SO THE BREEZE PROJECT --
WAS ONE ONE LARGE PROJECT THAT
WAS IT LIKE AS YOU STATED WAS
SUPPOSED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL FORTY BOREDOM
HEROES IN THE END.
TOOK -- IMPLEMENTED.
TWENTY A WE TOOK THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THAT PROJECT AND WE
CREATED AN OVERLAY AND A
STRATEGY THAT I WAS.
SPEAKING ABOUT BEFORE THAT WE
BELIEVE -- CAN ADDRESS THE
SEVENTEEN BOARDS AND THAT
OVERLAY WAS SUCCESSFUL WITH THE
CANNABIS -- IMPLEMENTATION THE
AGILE -- IMPLEMENTATION THAT WE
UTILIZE THEIR WHAT IS.
BASED ON LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE BREEZE PROJECT AS WELL AS
OUR OWN EXPERIENCE -- LANDING
RELEASED TO FOR BREEZE WHICH WAS
WIDELY ACKNOWLEDGED AS A MUCH
BETTER IMPLEMENTATION AND
RELEASE.
ONE AND THAT CANNABIS PROJECT
LANDED VERY WELL IN THE
AGGRESSIVE TIME FRAME THAT WAS --
THAT THE LAW REQUIRED IN JAN.
ONE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE.
WE ARE ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS
OF THE BREEZE PROJECT THE
LESSONS LEARNED STATE BOARD OF
AUDIT FINDINGS AS WELL AS OUR
OWN EXPERIENCE LANDING PRIEST TO
BREEZE RELEASED [inaudible]
TO AND SEVENTEEN PROJECTS --
HAVE PRESENTED TO YOU A SCHEDULE
THAT IS TOO FAR OUT BE HAPPY TO
CONSIDER THE SCHEDULE. TO
RECONSIDER THE SCHEDULING AND TO
BRING IN THAT DATE MORE BUT
WE'RE REALLY AGAIN OVERLAYING
THAT SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY THAT
WORKED WITH CANNABIS VERY WELL.
OVER SEVENTEEN TIMES AND SO --
THAT'S WHY THE SCHEDULES LITTLE
IS IS -- ELONGATED -- I WILL SAY
THAT THE FOLKS THAT WE WORKED
WITH THE BOARD SKEWS ME THE
BOARD'S RUSSELL WE'VE WORKED
WITH.
HAVE FOUND.
GREAT VALUE IN THE ARTIFACTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRODUCED IN THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE PROJECT I
BELIEVE WERE -- UP ABOVE FIVE
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
MANAGEMENT SESSIONS AND MY OVER
STATING THAT -- EIGHT HUNDRED
ARTIFACTS BUSINESS ARTIFACTS
THAT HAVE COME FROM THAT.
AS WELL AS THOUSANDS OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT IS SHOW THE
PROGRESS THAT -- THE FIRST
COHORT TO FIRST GROUPING OF
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN --
PROGRAMS HAVE HAVE UNDERTAKEN --
AND SO I I JUST WANTED TO
PERSIST PRESENT THAT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE STRATEGY --
DONE OVER SEVENTEEN TIMES IS
WHAT THIS IS WHAT IS CREATING A
LOT LONGER SCHEDULE BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE STRATEGY AGAIN
VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH CANNABIS.
IS.
A PATHWAY FOR YOU -- TO TO BRING
SICK MORE SUCCESSFUL IT PROJECTS
TO BEAR LIKE CANNABIS WAS UNDER
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND AND JUST TO MORE
OBSERVATIONS.
I HOPE THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
LEARNED LESSONS FROM WHAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO IN THE PAST BUT
TYPICALLY IF YOU LEARN LESSONS
YOU'RE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO THINGS FASTER.
IN THE FUTURE AND IT JUST SEEMS
AGAIN IS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE -- THREE
MORE TERMS THROUGH MORE
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS OF NEW
GENERATIONS OF LEGISLATORS WHO
COME HERE IF WE'RE NO LONGER ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND AND I'M JUST
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT -- THE
CONTINUITY OF THIS SO -- I'M
JUST NOT PREPARED TO SUPPORT
THIS AT THIS TIME WHICH WE JUST
NEED TO HAVE.
BETTER PLANS AND AND MORE
CERTAINTY THAT -- THAT -- THE
HOUSES ARE BEING KEPT -- WELL.
YES SO SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
I WOULD I LIKE FROM YOU WITHIN
THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO IS THE
INITIAL ONE BREEZES STOOD UP
INITIAL COST TO STAND RESULT.
IN EACH YEAR.
OF THE BC PIECES SUBMITTED AND
HOW MUCH MONEY WAS REQUESTED AND
GRANTED EACH YEAR.
SO FROM -- NINE TO PRESENT DAY
TODAY AND THEN ON THE HAND OUT
ON PAGE FORTY THREE THE THE
CHART YOU HAVE SOME THESE THINGS
SAYS DELAYED -- DELAYED IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE -- GIVE A SMART DATES
AND NOT REALLY SURE WAS DELAYED.
YOU'VE GOT ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE DID IN HERE BUT DELAYED
COULD BE.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX IN ALL AT WHAT
POINT DO YOU NOT KNOW THE LATEST --
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY IT IS --
THERE WE HAVE DATES THEIR WORK
WAS OPERATIONAL -- NEED -- TO
THE SCHEDULE FOR TOO SMALL OF
OUR SMALLER BOARDS FOR A
RESOURCE PURPOSES AND WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT SO THOSE WE CAN BUT I
THINK WHEN YOU COME THE PEOPLE
THAT FUND YOUR PROJECT.
NEED TO HAVE A HARD DATE.
DO A DELAYED IS I MEAN I'M NOT
UNDERSTAND THEY DOESN'T IT DOES
NOTHING FOR ME.
SO A LOT OF OUR COMMENTS HERE --
THE REMOTELY THIS ITEM WOULD
HOLD OPEN.
THERE'S FRUSTRATION HERE WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST YEAR THIS
IS NOTHING NEW NO NEW WORDS ARE
BEING SAID TODAY.
SO IF THERE'S ANY CHANCE THIS
GETTING PASSED THROUGH.
SOMETHING IS HAPPENING.
SO.
NEXT ITEM FOR A PUBLIC COMMONS
AUTUMN.
OKAY WE'RE DONE.
NEXT AUTOMATION OF RATE
STATEWIDE HUMAN RESOURCES
WORKLOAD
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
AFTERNOON.
GREETINGS COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MY
NAME IS H. REGION GETS JONES AND
I'M THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
CALLIE CHAR.
CALLIE JARS REQUESTING EIGHT
POSITIONS AND ONE POINT TWO SIX
MILLION FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND ONE POINT. NINE ONE
POINT NINETEEN MILLION FOR
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ONGOING.
THIS REQUEST ALIGNS WITH THE
STRATEGIC ROADMAP FOR
MODERNIZING.
STATE GOVERNMENT HR SYSTEMS AND
PROCESSES THE REQUESTED
POSITIONS IN FINDING WILL ALLOW
CAL HR TO EVOLVE CURRENT
STATEWIDE RESOURCES INTO
INTEGRATED STATEWIDE PROGRAMS
THAT COMBINE.
PROVIDE AND ENHANCE CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES FOR STATE DEPARTMENTS
LIMITED EXAMINATION AN
APPOINTMENT PROGRAM EXAMINATION
DEVELOPMENT WORKFORCE PLANNING
STATEWIDE RECRUITMENT HR
MANAGEMENT AND LEADERSHIP
PERFORMANCE AND CAREER
DEVELOPMENT.
WERE BAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
L. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM -- THANKS TO
LOOKING FOR THE MAN REYES ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL HIGH OVER OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE IS STILL EVALUATING
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
FOR NEW OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION.
BECAUSE BUDGET REQUEST A STAFF
PERSON SUPPORT THE OFFICE.
WILL HOLD OPEN THIS ITEM INTO
DECISION BEEN MADE ABOUT THE THE
PROPOSAL. FOR GOING HOLES ITEM
OPEN NECKLACES ARE HEARING THANK
YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY.
VOTE I'M SORRY.
SO REALLY GO AHEAD AN ADD ON MR
LACKEY -- WE WILL TAKE UP BY
VITAL ISSUES.
WANT. TO SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY SIX MR.
LACKEY WE CAN WORK UP -- ONE
THREE SEVENTEEN NINETEEN TO
NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY FOUR AND
THE TWENTY SIX OKAY.
IN THE VITAL ISSUES. EIGHT HELLO
SECOND.
BULLY ISSUES EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FIVE HOPE WOULD ALLOW TWENTY
FIVE IT'S LIKE IT'S JUST
EIGHTEEN ONLY.
YOUR NO.
ONE EIGHTEEN OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI.
IN ONE TO SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX JULY YES.
OKAY -- SERGEANTS WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES FOR
THE UP THE MEMBERS.
WE LET THEM NOW [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
THREE YEAH.
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE LACKEY HI [inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
I THINK THAT.
IT WAS.
VERY NICE -- YEAH [inaudible]
SO WE'RE THANK YOU STAND UP.
FOR OKAY SO --
WHAT IS IT?
OKAY VOTE ON ISSUES MOTHER
SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY SIX AND THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE MOTION TO
APPROVE THESE ITEMS.
IN THE VITAL ISSUES EIGHTEEN
MOTION TO APPROVE.
AND THEN ON OUR ACTION ITEMS.
THERE WERE [inaudible]
THREE ISSUE [inaudible]
ISSUE [inaudible]
THREE AND FIVE PLEASE SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING HAVE A NICE DAY